Warhammer 40k Inquisitor Mota
places the secret agents of the grim
future into an action-rpg and pits them
against the various enemies of mankind
your mission is to purge the Imperium of
men from corruption and to achieve this
goal you must fight in this violent
universe battles are not only vicious
and bloody but they also feel as real as
possible just like the fully
destructible environments in the game
Kombat surf has officially spectacular
reminder that in this future there is
only war every bolt of shots every chain
sword strike has an impact hits slowed
down enemies grenade blasts who send
heretics flying opponents fall down and
try to get back on their feet
unholy armor shatters to pieces carnage
in shoes in addition to all that the
more challenging fights just got some
extra flavor aimed attacks at joint foes
can destroy body parts getting rid of
special abilities by shooting up a
weapon arm you can make sure that you're
at least safe from the deadly fire
take your time intact those monsters
apart piece by piece
the game evokes a sense of brutal
warfare where no one is safe you can use
that to your advantage when you're
fighting the filth of chaos from time to
time you'll face demons that simply
don't care about their king and gladly
sacrifice their own in the crossfire
violence begets violence and sometimes
you'll need to strike down as brutally
as possible fatality is an integral part
of the game where each pass can use
special execution moves to finish off
most creatures and they all perish
differently
Inquisitor Mota is not for the
faint-hearted inquisitors must wait into
the thick of the battle where gushing
blood spatters on the walls spilled
entrails stains the floor severed limbs
twitch among the Fallen bodies there are
countless ways to dispose of the enemies
of the mighty Imperium and in this game
you'll have your chance to try them or
incinerate your foes cut them to pieces
blast them to smithereens or use the
elements of the environment against them
in this universe you need to fight fire
with fire and for this reason blood and
gore plays an important part in
Inquisitor mater
welcome to the grim world of Warhammer
40k